you be staying on your video [ __ ] man i  feel like you drop visuals consistently  yeah  like you don't like let nobody forget  about you you know what i'm saying i  can't though  that's what it's about though  putting it in their face you gotta you  gotta be right there yeah like is that  something that you conscious like like  you do on purpose like make sure that  like yo we keep feeding feeding the fan  base if this is what you if this what  you doing it's like why not  do it hey what you what you sitting  around waiting for yeah i got videos all  in the cut  i could drop every day of the week right  now if i want to that's crazy i got  stuff in the cup i just sit on it  wait so  it's better to have it than to not have  it 100 man